you don't remember anything I say huh  yeah really melodramatic didn't my told  me that you weren't really on a vacation  even with a job or your good boyfriend  didn't work out you are out of control  I've actually thanks during the bedroom  what and since you didn't have any money  you decided to move back here anything  else  [Music]  don't remember anything the  unprecedented nature of isn't a best  hang around though you're watching  something's gonna change and powers in  history all right  is this nervous tic I have and it's a  good thing up here  same place exact same time but it just  made a bunch of weird hand justice  show you guys something  it's good for dancing like ocean was  that a helicopter literally the pilot  and everything  in a good show  oh she's the monster  you